so we're home it's our first day home
and
alex is getting shy ready for the day
baby botan is still in the nicu it's a
very weird feeling 90 day fiance star
lauren brevarnick is sharing her
emotional time at home following the
early arrival of her newborn son who
remains in the nicu we're going to go
see him later today
and i hope that you all have a fabulous
friday earlier this week the reality
star and her husband alexei bravarnick
announced the baby's birth on instagram
and lauren revealed that she and her son
were recovering after he was born
prematurely she shared a series of
photos from the hospital and wrote in
the caption quote truly a thankful
thursday baby boaten has arrived much
earlier than expected due to some
circumstances he's in the nicu but
recovering well we can't wait to bring
him home and start this next chapter as
a family of four proud papa alexi also
posted a few photos of his own and in a
follow-up post lauren shared a video
with details of their new baby boy who
has yet to be named and thanked fans for
their outpouring of love
baby botan arrived
late
monday
august 16th in the evening
and
he came in at a whopping
five pounds uh nine ounces
19 inches tall
he is actually the same size that shai
was when shy was born and i can't wait
to share him with you
and i can't wait for shy to meet him
again so
from the bottom of my heart you guys
thank you thank you thank you
so much don't make me cry because i've
cried enough already today
lauren and alexi welcomed their first
son shy in april 2020 and announced they
were expecting their second child
together in march
e.t spoke with the two in may where they
revealed how their marriage has changed
since becoming parents
i think it's made us stronger
no it definitely puts you through a
couple loops but but we've gotten
through it i think it's actually taught
us to communicate more for real like we
talk about everything now and i think
our problems are fighting are going to
happen when they're older because i'm
like a nervous nellie now it's just like
no go head first and i'm like oh no bugs
hand sanitizer you know so i think
that's when our fighting is really going
to happen
but for now i think it's really made us
stronger we see different sides of each
other another hurdle lauren faced being
pregnant with tourette's syndrome she
candidly shared how it affected her
second pregnancy and how alexi showed
his support i do have my moments and
i've noticed them now with this
pregnancy they're definitely a lot worse
especially at night
um and there will be times where i text
him like i'm ticking so bad i don't know
why i don't know what's going on and
he's like your body is changing like
it's your body releasing the changes so
he's been very understanding and
supportive but
i now understand
when it's affected most of the time you
know so it definitely helps me in my day
to day and we decided not to really
stress about it because there's nothing
we can do about it for having kids we're
having a big family and
if any of them